actually it wasn't as bad i'm Cheska I'm
Taylor and I'm yen and we both love oat
milk and alcohol beverages with oat milk
and so we thought why not yeah yeah do
you like milk I mean I think of all of
the bougie non-dairy milks oat milk is
my favorite she's young she's fresh on
the scene I guess I really have no
opinion except I don't know it's a nice
substitute if something else you don't
like it
I think rum like oh yeah sort of like
going that sort of like tropical vibe
first things first vodka because she's
my main absolutely damn got our glasses
got our vodka ice got ice we got a whole
bunch oh you want to measure you don't
we'll just go for it you just want to go
for it hell yeah okay I'm gonna let you
do it then
how many shots of vodka all right let's
get the race right you know I think that
sounds like a good race I used to be a
bartender you can tell huh yeah yeah
sure I've been to bars I'm never
bartending cheers Cheers it smells like
rubbing alcohol you know what I don't
care with it I mean vodkas like one of
the we flavorful alcohols it just kind
of sits there and stings a little it
doesn't taste bad it smells worse than
it tastes yeah I just want it to taste
like juice and then I get drunk for like
20 minutes later but this is not that
kind of you know vodkas pretty neutral I
think that whiskey would Friday's all
right with this I always thinking the
same thing yeah yeah yeah I'm worried
about the gym Gina's gonna be a disaster
oh my god I think Romans yeah rums gonna
be good too the good thing about rum is
that you can start putting them in baked
goods and then it tastes really good I'm
gonna do it you're gonna measure I'm
gonna measure
she's precise I'm anticipating this is
gonna have a more like tropical vibe to
it something a little more I like the
way that color lives it's like baby kids
making in a nice caramel you know we're
inside with associate juice
that smells better a side captain no
it's fine
I don't mind that yeah I would drink
that Oh actually that's good yeah I
would drink this yeah cuz like oat milk
has that like OD quality to it like it's
like a leftover bowl of oatmeal and this
is like you'd support a little bit of
rum in there yeah and honestly like
that's pretty good
this could be a [ __ ] eggnog yeah
deck the halls baby like open milks a
really good substitute for like eggnog
I'm like really I almost finish it I
will finish this one Jim is very
refreshing when mixed with something
like tonic don't you a gin shot that's
not like that's not supposed to be a
thing I don't think I did that one time
in college and that's a dark place you
don't have to go there oh god I feel
like it's not even like mixing good just
because I don't like gin I like gin good
for you
I'm gonna take another set because it's
like actually kind of refreshing and I
don't know why it's oral nature there's
already something very earthy and then
you add like something also earthy like
made of oat and they just kind of bring
each other out I'm surprised I know I am
in shock I would do this again at my
house I can see how someone will like
this that someone isn't me very smelly I
think this one might be my favorite so
far
it was just me because it was just so
surprising it just doesn't leave that's
the thing like you got a vodka it went
away this one looks like clinging to
every corner of my mouth tequila
well I am from with the Jose
specifically but I don't think they'll
mix well together I don't know I feel
like with tequila like citrusy fruity
yeah better but I feel like tequila's
very it's got a big range I think I was
unprepared for this moment
that'll be fine tequila take oh that's
gross
that's pretty gross yeah I'm speechless
I keep drinking the dough I don't know
why I keep but it's better it's the
second best but it's not close to rum we
might have hit that tipping point we're
in tequila
hey tequila can I keep the bottles I'm
hoping this tastes like winter it's like
when it's cold out but you're cozy and
there's a fireplace this is what I'm
hoping it you want to measure you want
to go for it Rob you look just do it I
think is gonna taste close to rum but
not quite yeah I think it's gonna be the
second best it's gonna be yeah just
smelling it it smells all right no cheer
something so weirder yeah I like the rum
better I think there's more like Roundy
yeah like oh it makes it taste like kind
of like dusty and gross
you've got the Kentucky grit coming to
it to make its presence known but it's
not like overbearing I think surprising
with rum coming in a close second yeah
like I would boil that Christmas time
yeah the tequila was heinous I think I
only took one sip because after that I
said never again the vodka was pretty
bad too I like as a girl who likes vodka
who sticks with vodka cocktails wasn't a
fave it wasn't meant to be
I would never drink genital healthy no
Jenna no milk was by far the most
disgusting thing I drank I spit it out
and didn't even finish it so the gin was
offensive
the tequila which is a little bit out of
place yeah and vodka is just kind of
like your basic friend that can kind of
fit in anywhere
and the whiskey whiskey is your your
best friends like rock twin oh okay
rum is like your best friend yeah drink
your oat milk responsibly
[Music]